well there was an awful lot of Newsday
in Washington along with the drama over
the IG report newly released today also
brought another round of impeachment
hearings in the House Judiciary
Committee during those hearings
congressman Matt gates of Florida got
into it with the chairman Jerry Nadler
of New York over Nablus refusal to make
congressman Adam Schiff testify before
the committee here's how it went
implication is we want shift in that
chair not you the implication is the
person that wrote the report is the
person that should come and present it
and you weren't elected by anybody and
you're here getting this testimony in
place of the Chairman it does not I hope
that clears up the implication gentleman
does not have the time and the gentleman
has been warned before he cannot simply
yell out and disrupt the committee yeah
not allowed to make rational points on
the hill congressman Matt Gaetz of
Florida joins us in studio tonight so it
looks like you cleared up that
implication I may not be on Jerry Nadler
Christmas card list anymore in you know
where I'm from you stand behind your
work if Adam Schiff really believes the
president should be impeached as a
result of this conduct he ought to show
up and take our questions based on his
bias his contact with the whistleblower
and anything he was doing outside the
bounds of the law instead it was take
your donor to work day in the House
Judiciary Committee where some of the
left's big donors were able to come in
and literally ask each other questions I
mean it was this dystopian reality where
I'm watching one Democrat donor ask
questions of another Democrat donor
about issues that we could all read
about but they just want to give their
hot takes such a nice description the
whistleblower are we ever going to have
public confirmation of this person's
identity and does it matter well it just
depends on the day you know originally
it was Adam Schiff who said the only way
to resolve this dispute was to hear from
the whistleblower and then later when
the whistleblowers potential connections
to members of Adam shifts committee or
potential connections to presidential
campaigns started to leak out in public
reporting well then all of a sudden
nobody wanted to hear from the
whistleblower anymore so who knows what
tomorrow will bring without using his
name are you satisfied that the person
who's been identified as a whistleblower
is indeed look I don't know who the
whistleblower is the only member of
Congress who knows who the whistleblower
is is Adam Schiff sure all right in a
few minutes we'll be speaking with Ken
Starr about today's impeachment hearings
but first we want to get to this we want
to ask the Congress
about the terror attack at the Naval Air
Station Pensacola now the shooting was
in your district was committed by a
Saudi Air Force officer and several
other study officers are being
investigated this hour as collaborators
a question the obvious one is a time for
us and the base of this and other facts
to reevaluate our relationship with
Saudi Arabia the first thing we need to
do is join Governor De Santis this call
for the kingdom to step up for the
victims the second thing we need to do
is what Senator Graham and I will be
calling for and that is an immediate
suspension of the program where we bring
Saudis here to the United States without
sufficient vetting to stop something
like this and then we put ourselves at
risk and then absolutely we need to
support the FBI's investigation and not
allow anything to impair it but at some
point we've got to look at this
relationship more broadly tucker and
wonder how much from Saudi Arabia are we
willing to take well especially since we
we don't even have a definitive answer
about the Saudi government's role in
9/11 I mean and you don't think it's
definitive I think it's pretty
definitive that members of the Saudi
government were involved in supporting
the us-based activities of some of those
[ __ ] I stand corrected that is exactly
right I think some of the tails remain
hidden from us least from public view by
the US government what's baffling to me
is how there is resilient bipartisan
support for maintaining this
relationship with one of the creepiest
most repressive nations on earth when
we're energy independent why are we
doing this well because they trade in
the u.s. they trade oil in the US dollar
I mean if if you really want to have a
little truth talk about Saudi Arabia's
it's that we need them selling oil in
the US dollar in order to maintain the
dominance of the dollar to be able to
make our sanctions effective elsewhere
in the world especially among
oil-producing nations but that is not a
reason to turn a blind eye to Saudi
potential involvement in 9/11 in the
shooting in Pensacola in look when we
look at this war in Yemen Saudi Arabia
is engaged in all kind of terrible
atrocious activities and we continue to
sell them arms if the people who
committed those murders or colluded on
9/11 were Iranians we'd have troops in
Tehran right now and I'd probably
support it actually I think I think
there's a good amount of Washington that
would like to have troops in Tehran by
lunchtime tomorrow but that's just the
thirst for regime change wars that I'm
glad you and I stand against
from Matt Gaetz great to see you tonight
thank you very much